[Applaus]
sehr geehrte präsident meine damen und
herren wenn ein gesetz zur behebung
eines fachkräftemangels
damit beginnt dass es eine
arbeitsmarktöffnung für jeden gibt auch
in staaten wo gerade kein mangel
herrscht auch da wo ein deutscher oder
einer der millionen arbeitssuchenden eu
stadler den job machen könnte
das will man aber nicht wissen wegfall
der vorrangprüfung auch da wo der
einreisende überhaupt keine jobzusage
hat und keine klare qualifikation dann
ist klar worum es dieser regierung geht
um immer weitere zuwanderung nach
deutschland gern fremd kulturell wie
beim globalen migrations packt der
migration als ziel an sich fördern will
so im globalen flüchtlings pakt mit
umsiedlung schon in sicherheit
befindlicher personen wohin dürfen sie
raten wie bei dublin 3 der migrant
verbleibt dem ersten tritt start von der
kanzlerin mal eben für obsolet erklärt
so in dublin 4 1 reise dorthin wo man
angeblich bekanntheit wo das ist dürfen
sie raten das alles ist
verantwortungslos schädigung
deutschlands als kanzler richtlinien
will man aber wissen wes geistes kind
diese regelungen sind schaut man nach
berlin dem versuchslabor für rot-grünen
weltuntergang da will die spd einen
krankenschein für anonyme illegale
medizinische vollversorgung für 50.000
komplett unberechtigte auf
beitragszahler kosten unterstützung von
rechtsbruch durch rot rot grün wäre dass
künftig auch im bund haben will braucht
nur eine dieser parteien zu wählen oder
die union die mit grünen kuschelt deren
vorsitzender sich mit der aussage es
gibt kein volk zur kanzlerschaft
qualifiziert wie würde wohl seine
amtszeit laufen
der innenminister wollte in seinem
fachkräfte gesetz keine neuen
bildungsansprüche das hat er geschafft
all die verheerenden ausweitungen der
duldung sie stehen jetzt versammelt im
giftschrank des ausgelagerten parallel
gesetzes zur duldung einer bad bank der
schrott paragrafen da sollen alle die
hunderttausende nicht schutzbedürftigen
asylbetrüger
per spurwechsel im land bleiben als lohn
der lüge den unrechts kadetten charakter
verdecken sollen bedingungen die
herstellbar sind deutschkurse besuchen
mal in ausbildung gehen wer mag ihn
nicht den herzigen jungen afrikaner der
für die tv reportage fröhlich integriert
an seiner schraube dreht nein meine
damen und herren das ergebnis von
permanenter zuwanderung mangelnde
abschiebung spurwechsel und
familiennachzug ist eine schnell
wachsende menge nicht integrierter
menschen dieses bildungsgesetz hebel
doch abschiebung aus macht auch dem
letzten klar man will sowieso alle
behalten dafür bekommen wir auch etwas
zurück massiv sinkende bildung in kitas
und schulen leistungsabfall in handwerk
und hochschulen leer und ordnungskräfte
die dem schon jetzt nicht mehr gewachsen
sind
es gibt ein gegenmodell stadt illegale
und betrüger zu päppeln leistungen für
den deutschen staatsbürger dafür steht
die afg und zwar nur die afd
nächster redner